a tick is one of the most dangerous
things on the planet
even though it may not look like it a
single bite
could affect you for the rest of your
life
but how can this happen exactly on
today's challenge
we're going to show you what happens
when you get bitten by a tick
would it make you feel sick or
would you not even notice this
is your body on a tick bite
ticks are not insects they're
parasitic arachnids that can be as small
as a poppy seed they're capable
of carrying more diseases than any other
arthropod
but not all ticks are disease carriers
the most common disease transmitting
species
is the blacklegged tick also known as
the deer tick
what if a disease-ridden deer tick bit
you
how quickly would you feel the effects
if
at all okay you're hiking through a
meadow of tall grass on a warm spring
day
little do you know that it's prime tick
season and
you'll be bringing home a stowaway
ticks don't always latch on right away
they sometimes spend an hour or two
searching for the perfect
place to feast often where there is
thin skin near a blood vessel when a
tick finally finds the perfect
place to extract your blood it burrows
its head
into your skin it unleashes a feeding
tube
and secretes blood thinning skin numbing
saliva
not only did it bite you but you didn't
even feel it
the tick has likely been feeding on a
moist
area on your body like your groin or
armpits
and by now the tick is much larger than
a poppy seed
having gorged on your blood for over 24
hours
there are many diseases transmitted by
ticks
like the powassan virus and the rocky
mountain spotted fever but
the most well-known tick-borne ailment
is lyme disease a 2014 study found that
only one to three percent of people
bitten by a tick
carrying lyme disease will become
infected
but the centers for disease control and
prevention says
the number of reported cases of lyme
disease in the united states
has tripled since the late 1990s
luckily disease transmission is not
instantaneous the cdc says that if the
tick
is removed within 24 hours your chances
of getting lyme disease are low
unfortunately you continue to go about
your day
not realizing that there's a sucking
parasite
attached to your body
okay you've finally noticed the tick
as it has become engorged and grown to
three times its original size oh that's
nasty
now it's time to remove it
get some tweezers and grasp the tick
close to your skin's surface pull
straight up
and away from the skin applying steady
pressure
do not bend or twist the tick
next check the bite to see if any of the
tick's head
remains and carefully remove it
clean the bite with soap and water then
submerge the tick in rubbing alcohol to
make sure it's dead
you'll notice a solid red oval that
looks like a bull's eye at the bite site
it's probably nothing it'll go away in a
couple of days right
the tick debacle is behind you but
much to your dismay it left a sinister
parting gift the red bull's eye remains
at the bite site and you've developed a
full body rash
and over the past four weeks you've had
persistent headaches
neck stiffness and aches everywhere
plus you're nauseous as the month has
progressed you're experiencing a fever
and chills
you notice that your lymph nodes are
swollen
you assume it's just a bug and not the
blood-sucking disease-carrying kind
so you take some painkillers and ride it
out
after months your symptoms have gotten
even
worse on top of feeling sick all the
time
you've also had a hard time
concentrating and
remembering things you've finally
decided to see a doctor you've been
diagnosed with
lyme disease if you spotted this tick
six months ago and
went to the doctor right away this
disease
would have been easier to treat you may
not even have
got it in the first place you'll need
antibiotics right away
luckily there's hope you'll get back to
normal but
it could be a long road to recovery
even after antibiotics people who have
lyme disease
can experience symptoms for up to six
months
but if you seek medical attention you
will eventually recover
i got better hopefully
you can avoid something like this
happening after all
the key to preventing lyme disease is
making sure
a tick never latches onto you in the
first place
when exploring the outdoors wear long
pants with
socks pulled up over your ankles after
you get home
check for ticks especially on your head
legs and ankles and don't forget to
check your pets
a tick bite can affect them as well
although getting a tick bite can come
with some serious consequences
you did manage to survive but
what about another challenge with the
far
lower survival rate like being
allergic to everything well
we'll see what that challenge brings on
the next episode of
world body on